now every once in a while an on-air
exchange slips through the cracks on one
of the other cable networks that's worth
watching
such was the case this morning on cnn of
all places where they booked a point
counterpoint on critical race theory
schools should absolutely be teaching
reading writing arithmetic they should
not be radicalizing our kids and
unfortunately
schools are now radicalizing our kids i
mean this is the volume of the book from
critical race theory that as you people
say teach in law schools but
unfortunately it is now trickling down
into little books for children like woke
baby
genderqueer in it there is unfortunately
very graphic symbol of pedophilia and
pornography azra nomani who's been a
guest frequently on the angle over the
years came armed with tabbed copies of
the books used in the schools with
specific page citations and a very calm
thorough irrefutable presentation that
left the host kind of grasping
entered the defender of critical race
theory in this discussion a guy who was
billed as simply a concerned parent but
who actually works the diversity equity
and inclusion racket in austin texas
telling companies and individuals to
check their white privilege and
re-examine their obsession with
merit-based hiring turns out that's a
lucrative business
but money can't buy you logic instead of
refuting ms nomani's evidence proving
the poisonous effects of crt curricula
he
merely pulled a terry mcauliffe
saying parents should generally stop
butting in leave education to the
experts presumably experts like him
of too many people who know little or
nothing about education trying to tell
professionals who are in this industry
who've been working hard we're coming in
as weekend lawyers trying to tell them
about what education should look like we
need to put a little bit more trust in
our educators because they've actually
spent the time and energy necessary to
really understand some of the nuances
that they're being kind of just blown
over here in this conversation
now what does any of that mean you may
wonder well it means it's not yours to
question these topics are simply too
complex for the little people to
understand
yet
what's there to understand about reading
assigned to our children that associates
white people with the devil
it literally says here
whiteness is a bad deal and it has a
symbol of
satan
and this is the contract that they say
whiteness
brings and children are getting this
book
and i fit into the intersectional world
i'm a muslim i'm an immigrant i'm a mom
of color
i
am a single mom
but yet i deny all of these
you know privileges in the new
paradigm of the oppression matrix
because we're all human beings
that miss namani is highly educated in a
minority herself doesn't matter
for the dei cabal all that matters is
marketing guilt and shame to schools
corporations entertainers and sports
figures and of course the churches are
in on the act each comes under enormous
pressure to comply
they prove their dei bonafides by
linking to goofy dei posters like this
one
or by hiring people not on merit but
according to the latest woke rules
and of course by shunning anyone who
refuses to mouth their platitudes or who
questions their goals
dei propaganda likes ccp propaganda
must never be questioned by the
unenlightened masses
the language i'm hearing used here
doesn't really speak to the level of
sophistication that i think is necessary
to help our young people be prepared for
the world of work for the society that
they're going to be living in
as someone who worked in universities we
had too many students who were coming to
the university who had little or no
experience of knowing how to navigate
the conversations and relationships that
were related to race
what gibberish don't you feel better
about paying that fat college tuition
now
but you may not know it not schools and
businesses are desperate to check the
diversity equity inclusion box
that they'll either hire a full-time dei
coordinator or they'll feel like they
have to hire random dei consultants they
find on the web
meet riru bossim founder of boston
consulting inc
her firm is described as a
world-renowned full-service dei
consulting firm dedicated to driving
organizational change
when i say whiteness i'm talking about
the embodiment of white american white
anglo-white euro-centric ways of
behaving
put you in a place where you are better
more deserving uh more competent and
more over people who embody behaviors
that connect back to communities of
color and indigenous communities
and how
and the connection between racism and
white supremacy is that
racism is a
manifestation of white supremacy
what a terrible way to make a living
no real knowledge of history zero
appreciation of the great blessings of
liberty and opportunity that america
provides
only resentment politics and a lot of
hand movements
and yes the point of this is to turn
neighbor against neighbor student
against student citizen against country
white populous has always been
susceptible to manipulation around
racial animus this is really about white
people and particularly white children
now being exposed to ideas that i think
previously were segregated frankly
if your children's school teaches this
nonsense demand that your son or
daughter be permitted to opt out in
favor of i don't know those
unaccomplished writers like hemingway
fitzgerald twain harriet beecher stowe
other great american writers
but remember
the goals are always shifting for the
dei crowd 20 years ago it was tolerance
for different points of view
but that wasn't getting the far left
anywhere so then they shifted to
demanding diversity
but that too they found to be limiting
so they moved on again
lecturer paloma medina gave a tutorial
to a packed auditorium on how to
establish true racial and gender equity
in your workplace
we need to verbalize the right goal
the goal isn't diversity the goal is
equity
[Applause]
instead of saying that you're going to
form a diversity committee
hire outside experts to help you audit
for and then achieve equity in salary
and promotions you can do it in two
years
you can
look at those clapping seals in the
audience they don't even realize that
the speaker is shilling for her own
industry and her solutions would mean
forcing a lot of them in the audience
out of jobs and hiring others purely on
racial or gender lines
now the temptation is to laugh at this
cottage industry for the perpetually
aggrieved oh yeah but to do that is just
a mistake
real racism is repugnant
and everyone but the lowest of the low
know it
but what we're doing to our schools our
workplaces our everyday life is
corrosive and divisive
the only people we really help by hiring
firing or promoting people based on
immutable characteristics
are the people getting rich off teaching
bitterness and virtue signaling
where hard work and effort will usually
suffice
and remember they're not alone
every piece of this garbage that the
hard left spouts is now treated as
gospel by president biden and his entire
team
america has a long history
of systemic racism system immigration is
a stain on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans we must improve equity
within and between our countries
and close economic political and social
gaps that persist based on race gender
and other parts of our identity
they'll use every bit of their power and
that's a lot of power to force you to
live in a country dominated by the dei
police
which takes us back to that discussion
that caught my attention earlier today
what a great country it is that a
muslim-american woman who arrived here
not speaking our language is far better
versed in the guarantees of our
constitution and the meaning of our
declaration than countless native-born
dei experts not to mention
the buffoons now occupying the white
house
think of the tens of millions of
immigrants who've become small business
owners and successful professionals
and who did so by the way without
relying on government handouts or dei
mandates to clear the path for
themselves
so maybe just maybe it's time for us to
focus more on parenting and less
uncomplaining
more on showcasing talent
and less obsessing on race or ethnicity
and that's the angle i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis